it's time for CBS morning's deals where
we share some items that might make your
day a little bit better all at exclusive
discounts in this women's history month
we've been sharing some products from
women owned businesses to start shopping
now scan the QR code on your screen
right now or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle host Gail bass is
in the house hey good morning good
morning so let's start this thing off
because what do we have here something
that makes cooking a little bit easier
for the whole family it makes it easier
and healthier this is the air world
crispr what I love about this is that
you get your deepest pan a deeper pan
you put this airworld lid on it and it
works like an air fryer but remember
this is portable you could take it
camping you put it in a cabinet it's not
going to be a big machine a big bulky
air fryer yeah plus you're an athlete
Tony is an athlete your kids are
athletes this helps you eat healthier
because look here we've got all these
different kind of foods which are known
to be unhealthy if you fry them or if
you've got all that cheese you use this
device it cuts out on all that oil and
it helps helps make your food healthier
and the kids can use it here I'll show
you how it works I'm going to press this
button boom you put it on a deeper pan
like that and then I'm going to flip
this up and show you there it is there's
a little fan working I'll see what
you're saying and that thing oh over to
the left so it literally turns it into
an air fryer it works like an air fryer
yes yeah it makes your food healthier to
eat yeah healthier to eat only for 32.99
we have it for 45 off so it's a great
price I love the charge up okay okay
because my boyfriend's got Twins and uh
when I'm over there there's always like
I can't find my cord I can't find this
somebody always forgets their cord
whether they're traveling whether at
home they don't know where it is you use
this charge Hub you have something that
can charge virtually every device your
tablets your phones your readers and
they're multiple different styles and
colors so you have three four five yeah
plugins this one is four but it's also a
night light so when you right into the
wall he plugs into the wall so if you've
got a little one who's a little afraid
of the dark or you're traveling
somewhere and they have terrible
Lighting in the house boom you've got
that so you don't trip over that area
around I was just on vacation I could
have used this this is perfect for
spring break and for travel or for home
a home hub station in my office yeah
it's everywhere yeah and look at all
these short cords they're all compacted
together everything's close nothing to
lose and these start at 11.99 to 49.99
we have them for up to 62 off by the way
that's Wireless and isn't that a
beautiful color perfect I love the color
perfect I love the color all right so
what do we have here I'm really excited
about this all right me too this is
women's history month and we are
featuring some women-owned businesses
and I gotta say I love Kaylin Marcotte
she developed this she was busy working
for a startup and when she was working
for the startup she said starting to
puzzle helped her calm down helped her
to be more mindful I have to admit I
love to puzzle myself and I didn't admit
it as an adult because I just thought
I'm puzzling there are a lot of people
out there who love my daughter and I
just got into it this weekend yes for
any daughter date and brought some
puzzles home it is great daddy daughter
time is great family time and what's
great about this is this features
emerging artists so if you do one of
those puzzles they also send you some
glue so you could glue the puzzles
together it's an art piece and turn them
into art so right here let me move over
here let me show you this finished piece
I like to call this the Gale that's not
the name but this feels like me after
Sunday service in my yellow dress
thinking of Gail and her favorite color
oh yes and you know you put and you put
this together and you have art that you
worked on together I can't paint for
anything that goes over the top and
holds it in place yeah you put the glue
I think you put the glue on the back oh
and the back okay yeah and then you just
wipe it on they give you a little
spreader to put it on and you've got it
okay so perfect this is great we have a
range of prices that start at twenty two
dollars to 36.99 oh that is great Gail
Bash the best thank you so much thank
you all right of course we partnered
with all these companies to get these
deals to buy anything that you saw scan
the QR code on your screen right now or
head over to cbsdeals.com to start
shopping now we will be right back and
I'm taking these puzzles with me home